season two Jessi Cruickshank show new
mom who dis kicks off on October 9th on
Facebook watch and she's sitting down
with a pretty impressive first guest
prime minister justin trudeau he's
opening up like never before especially
when it comes to you talking about his
dad bod just fact-checking
do you have a dad bod I wouldn't know
how to define that would you like a
portly er I've let myself go because I
had kids I try to keep in shape
junu who appreciates that this woman
have you seen this it was taken at a
moment we were leaning in to kiss each
other on the cheek and and and the angle
makes it look different than it it
really does just this knee didn't forget
here just just like that just this
moment right here looks looks yes the
timing is often I'm back girl kiss on
both cheeks okay good Jesse also brought
in some kids to ask the Prime Minister
some questions and one of those
questions was about the controversy
surrounding the photos of Trudeau
wearing brown face okay I don't know if
you noticed we have twin twins here very
excited Soleil and solarath I'm gonna
stand up and ask a question what did you
paint you things down oh it was
something I shouldn't have done because
it hurt people um it's not something
that you you should do and that is
something that I learned I didn't know
it back then but I know it now
and I'm sorry I hurt people did you
paint your note and your hands man
mm-hmm
yeah and it was the wrong thing to do
and I had a good conversation with my
kids around taking responsibility for
mistakes and making sure that we're
always sticking up for each other and
not teasing each other and being
respectful towards each other I'm sorry
that I hurt you as well I'm sorry that I
hurt kids who you know get you know face
teasing and discrimination because
because of the color of your skin that's
just not right in this country or
anywhere in the world we all have to
work together to make sure that it
doesn't happen okay oh I know from one
kind of funny moment to a very serious
topic there Wyatt saying he needs good
PR right now I trick to sanctuaries hot
carry sank Debra Trudeau is in on the
joke when it comes to the dad bod HP cow
sing so cute that he is nervous and Noah
saying I wouldn't mind having Trudeau
that close to me just saying oh wow yeah
I know and Jesse just an amazing job I
think she should have her own show
actually to be honest is usually like
sure I'm putting it out there I think
she should be the late-night show
Canadian style anyways it's such a great
interview I'm glad that he's spoken with
her and and you're right it's fun and
also bring in the serious note of having
the child talk about brain frown face
it's so interesting that conversation
because I was asked that question and
how it if it disturbed me as well so
it's great I think it's a great if even
if it's a PR move it was great and I
think it said looking forward to it any
more of it yeah I was pretty shocked
with that even came up in the interview
yeah I loved him talking about dadbod
he's looking you know especially with
all the controversy surrounding
everything that happened he needs to
look more human to people and yeah like
a dad so I think this is a very
entertaining way elections are coming